joining us here now on the rich eisen
show uh is the uh
insider of the national football league
for sports illustrated and the author of
the mmqb albert prayer here on the rich
eisen show how you doing albert
i'm good i didn't think we'd have some
freddie mitchell talk on here fedex
right
i don't know if you guys if you guys
remember this but after that game after
that 4th and 26th i think he showed up
to the press conference wearing like an
indiana jones hat
and then immediately got up there and
thanked his hands
to mention that before brockman talked
about that exactly before albert i'd
like to thank my hands for being so
great today albert
yeah i would say uh that was a fantastic
moment um of that era didn't bill clown
him after the super bowl or something
too something yeah yeah bill did
something to i can't remember exactly
where it was maybe it was in the press
conference yeah he said
like i i can't remember what it was but
there was definitely something there
i'll find it so what do you mean bill
clowned him
clowns people yeah hold on a second i
know i think maybe after the super bowl
somehow he found a way to spike it in in
freddie's face i'm not sure exactly how
it happened but there was definitely
something there what was bill's beef oh
do you mean the next year after they
beat the eagles the next year i mean
we'll be as beef
you know after this yeah bill said after
the super bowl all he does is talk he's
terrible and you can print that i was
happy when he was in the game
wow
who do you say that to brockman
um really he said that in 2000 after
beating the eagles in jacksonville the
next year i remember that yeah i
was that that that couldn't have been a
press conference though right no i don't
no i don't think so no it's about to say
could could you imagine if bill said
something like that today you know on a
zoom or or on camera or something like
that i was happy he was in the game
there'd be smoke coming out of all of
our phones at that oh i got to be
incredible how about him apologizing
this week albert you've been in the
business end of many i don't know where
my apologies are like for all the years
i'm open to discussing things i'm a big
boy over here we can we can talk about
some things if he wants to wow i love it
albert breer here on the rich eisen show
okay so um j.c tretter the center of the
cleveland browns who also happens to be
the president of the
nfl players association said that um
the reason why games were postponed
is because the union
made sure they were because the league
wanted to cancel them over the weekend
and thus not pay players
um
what what's what's up with that what do
you got for me
it was really tricky rich i mean i i
know uh you know by the letter of the
the law and the way these things were
sort of spelled out in the summer um you
know the league had a right to cancel
the games if they cancel the games or
move the games or cause any sort of
forfeit then the players on both teams
um both both the teams would be uh it
would be
not paid and there was talk about
whether or not there were you know
protocol violations and that sort of
stuff and would this be a forfeit like
like would it be
if we move into tuesday
like how what sort of effect would that
happen you know i think the minute that
the players sort of got it on their
radar they're like wait a second like
they're gonna try not to pay us
then it was we need to find a way to
have these to get these games played you
know come hell or high water we're gonna
find a way to make sure everybody's out
there and accounted for and everybody's
getting paid and that's sort of where
they started working together towards
you know finding a solution and you know
obviously it wasn't ideal and i mean if
you look at it there's still a lot of
guys out you know on monday night or
monday afternoon and then last night of
course
um but i i know
you know once this thing sort of shook
out on wednesday and thursday and friday
the priority for the union became let's
make sure all of our guys get paid um
which you know i think is sort of what
kicked everything into overdrive as far
as trying to find a spot for the games
to be played where it wouldn't be
i guess overly disruptive to the season
huh so
um when it comes down to it the league
was willing to what like give
give the browns the loss on the spot
and
that eventually they did get or
it's interesting like washington
and
the rams are the only team that actually
won the game that got delayed you know
of all the teams that whose coveted
problems caused the delay or brought
about the delay right so yeah washington
loses cleveland loses and yeah i mean
the the the rams are the one team that
had the issue um that wound up winning
the game and i mean i
i you know again like i think like so
much of this was
like where are they digging around
what's the league looking for and what's
going to be best for all the players
involved and i i think
you know
put it this way rich if you want to look
for protocol violations
you can probably find some right you
know what i mean like if you wanted to
like go through the tapes and you wanted
to go through everything
like you could probably find something
and
i i think like a big thing for the union
became like if one or two guys flipped
up and then you know the league wants to
point to that one or two things those
one or two things and say we're
canceling the game this team's fourth
thing and nobody's getting paid i think
the union didn't want to allow the
leeway to do something like that you
know and i think both me and you i mean
me and you were on the air whatever it
was 10 years ago now you're talking
about how odds these sides have been um
the trust there you know i
you know i i i think it was a good place
last year because everybody was sort of
working towards the same conclusion
i i don't know this in the same place it
was before because i do think that there
was even you know on a global from a
global standpoint there was disagreement
you know what i mean like on well the
union wants you know daily testing the
league wants to get rid of testing
um for vaccinated guys there was just i
think there were some disagreements that
led up to this that led to
and maybe not fully trusting that the
league was on the level and so you know
at that point i think for the union the
priority becomes making sure that every
player winds up coming out of the
weekend with a paycheck mmqb's albert
prier here on the rich eisen show so
last spring and summer or more spring
maybe than summer when
the issue of
russell wilson's future in seattle was
front and center and he wound up staying
put
but the i think the general consensus
amongst everyone um
certainly observers
is that this season would have a lot to
to do with whether russell stays put or
wants to force his way out and if you
had told anybody back in the spring
that the longest regular season ever
uh
unfolding with seattle clinching
russell's first losing season in seattle
with three games left to play we would
have said that well that's that
what about now that that reality is hit
what do you think
oh i i think you know i i was one of the
people last year who said
the right thing for seattle to do
is to ride this thing out because
they've got a win now team with a 70
year old coach
um you know and some core players that
are aging ride this thing out and get
russell wilson on the team and and and
compete like hell to try to win a
championship in 2021
and figure out where you are after that
i'm not in that place anymore i mean i i
think you know like this is sort of
feels like it's coming to its conclusion
and then maybe the best thing for
everybody involved is a clean break and
i can tell you rich like unequivocally
like part of where russell was last
january
um you know i i think it was sort of
looking at it as like this is the start
of the second half of my career and he
was looking at things like am i going to
be a hall of famer how am i viewed
what's my legacy how what sort of
position am i going to be in to compete
for championship and that meant not just
looking at what he was doing which he
did you know it was
i like how am i training how am i eating
how am i getting myself ready for the
season who am i working with all that
stuff so you looked at all that on an
individual level but it was also is
everything around me right to be in a
position to compete for a championship
and to become maybe a league mvp which
he hasn't done and to ultimately wind up
in the hall of fame
and if he was asking those questions and
still like trying to force his way out
or at least rumbling about it last year
after i mean they were in the playoffs i
believe they won 12 games in the
division last year what do you think
he's going to be when they're five and
nine you know what i mean like so
i i i think that this thing is sort of
careening now towards you know the exit
ramp and
i like it just feels to me like
we're going to be a point in january
maybe it'll be like detroit and staffer
you know where
you know they have a meeting at the end
of the season and they come to a
conclusion what's best for everybody um
is that we just go our separate ways now
and it would give the seahawks a chance
to trade him when he's still got two
years left on his contract which would
probably allow them to get true value
for him so
my guess is that where we are right now
is moving very quickly towards russell
wilson probably being the first of those
quarterbacks to hit the trademark in
january and by the way yeah like being
there first can actually really benefit
you like i think detroit
benefited last year from getting ahead
of all those other you know situations
where they were able to get stafford out
there early enough there were a lot of
bidders on him and they got a good price
for him so what does it look like what
does something like that look like once
once it is uh known
at least uh amongst the burned up phone
lines or burning up phone lines that
russell wilson can be in fact had and
let's start the bidding
um
who who who makes those phone calls
do you think so like we had four teams
rich that like were i think sort of
involved at some level in deshaun watson
and i think those four teams are still
there uh as far as just what if there
are veteran quarterbacks available um
that are that of that level they'll be
in and so miami philadelphia carolina
denver i think would all at least
explore it
um and then i think we'd be looking at
some other teams where they've got young
quarterbacks and the decision to whether
or not to pay him is coming and so now
for those teams it's
what do we do do we move forward with
our young quarterback or with all these
accomplished veterans available do we
decide to flip them out sort of like
what the rams did last year flipping out
jared goff for matthew stafford and so
like the giants you know i think he'd
have an interest in going to new york
would the giants be the point where it's
like yeah it makes sense for us to flip
out daniel jones for russell wilson now
cleveland you know cleveland i think
would be an interesting one because
they're having to come to a decision
point on baker mayfield so
um those would be six teams that i think
would be in it you know and then i think
you have to consider teams like new
orleans who are you know i think in
tricky positions from a cab standpoint
pittsburgh's another one where you look
at them and you say okay
like yeah their situation's a little
sideways but creatively could they do
something because those could be places
that russell himself might want to go
hmm and i i'd i'd do that if i was
seattle certainly because they don't
have any draft choices
um in the first round this year they can
certainly replenish immediately and then
for the future
um what would that mean with pete
carroll what do you think do you think
people would even
to me it's a fascinating question does
he have a stomach for a rebuild you know
what i mean like right now that said
like i think we would have asked the
same question of belichick a year ago
where their roster was aging they were
able to flip it pretty quick and they
have some sharp personnel people up
there i mean you know john schneider and
they've been in a little bit of a slump
from a draft standpoint of late but
those things turn you know what i mean
that
becomes the first question if you are
going to move on from russell wilson is
because your 70 year old head coach
who's won a super bowl and been to two
for you does he what does he have the
stomach to go through what would be
probably a pretty significant rebuild
and i mean like that's the thing about
the roster rich like i'll ask you how
many guys that are young
they are like they think they're young
would you look at it as like building
blocks like cornerstones there guys that
are you could say like that guy could be
around in five years i mean to me i look
at it
dk metcalf and jamal adams and maybe
that's it right like bobby wagner's
older
dwayne brown's older like i just i look
at the roster it's like
i don't know like how many guys are
there now where you say yeah three or
four years from now this guy's gonna be
a cornerstone of the roster so you know
i i think that they just they need
capital and they need they need capital
to turn it around like they need to have
the capital to go get younger and i mean
obviously the most the easiest way to
create that capital would be to trade
your franchise quarterback and i guess
the question while we're talking about
turnover albert here on the rich eisen
show is how how how deep will the
turnover be for the giants and the bears
in front office coaching like like those
are some very interesting decisions that
membership slash ownership is going to
have to make in those spots what do you
think about that what do you think about
that sure the giants like
okay so i think
the the mayors love joe judge and and i
i think john mayer really feels despite
the record that he found something in
joe judge um despite you know what a lot
of people think and everything else like
i do think that like he's of a mind to
keep joe judge for 2022 i do think that
like whether it's by a retirement or
reassignment or firing him like i think
this probably is dave gellerman's final
year
and then the question i think becomes
whether or not you hire somebody who's
got background with joe um and the name
that i i know has been sort of out there
in personnel circles the last couple of
years is monty austin ford who had a
good relationship with joe worked with
him in new england who's the director of
player personnel in tennessee now
and so like if they hire monty awesome
for it that'd be a sign to me like okay
they're going forward for the next
couple years with joe and they're giving
him somebody that he's going to be able
to sort of build his own team with
or
do they just hire somebody else in which
case if you hire somebody else you know
what happens rich
now joe's under evaluation in 2022 right
and that gm might have a head coach that
he wants where joe's gonna have to kind
of convince him not to do that a year
later so i think that's sort of the spot
the giants are gonna be in in january
as for the bears
um you know i i think matt maggie's gone
and and i think you know ryan pace is
sort of
twisting in the wind to some degree and
i
you know i've heard some people say that
he could survive i've heard other people
say that they think he's gone
i think sean payton is actually an
interesting sort of piece here and
follow me here i think we talked about
this a couple weeks ago the idea of
trading for coaches well ryan pace came
up in the saints organization has a
really good relationship with sean
payton is it possible that ryan could
sell
bears ownership on i can deliver sean
payton and i can give you sean payton to
help develop justin fields
maybe something like that saves ryan
pace but i i think you know one way or
the other there's going to be a coaching
change and it's quite possible that
whether or not ryan pace survives maybe
depends on what ryan pace can pitch
ownership as the next phase of of where
the bears have gone i mean that's
something else certainly since they you
know
their first round draft choice belongs
to the giants this year for the
quarterback that would be the one that i
imagine would
remotely entice sean payton into
thinking about it you know as opposed to
staying put
um and finding the quarterback there
i mean he's from chicago no i mean of
course eastern illinois all that
business i i i hear you i mean i think i
think what's interesting about it you
know rich is like and i think we talked
about this couple weeks ago like it's to
me it's you know like for some of these
teams if you want to look creative and
you want to take a big swing on one of
these guys who's a sitting head coach
whether
it's you know mike tomlin or sean payton
or john harbaugh whoever it is like i i
do think like one way to look at this
creatively if you're one of those teams
is has that coach's natural conclusion
been reached where he's at you know and
i think with tom when you look at you
say is the gm is kevin colbert retiring
is ben roethlisberger retiring right
like with new orleans you say okay it's
a year past freeze now they've got cap
issues even with like a john harbaugh
it's like well they're going to pay
lamar jackson maybe the dynamic their
changes so is it worth and it's not
saying those guys have any interest in
leaving but it's just like there's a
natural reason why this might be the
time for a separation so it doesn't hurt
to ask they can say no right maybe john
and maybe john and and and mike and sean
don't want to go anywhere and maybe it's
a non-starter we've heard what mike
tomlin said about it right but you know
i think if you're one of these teams at
least behooves you to ask the question
right like if you're the raiders and you
need to remake who you are like who
would be a better guy to put in front of
all that than mike tomlin you know what
i mean like so like that doesn't mean
mike tomlin wants to go to vegas but why
not ask right like why not just knock on
the door and say if we threw you some
pics would you be interested in it i
mean i just think it's to me it's like a
creative way for these teams to start to
look at these things where
maybe
going the conventional route um isn't
the way to go because we've you know
we've seen over the years how the
pipeline's been dried dried up and
obviously you know i don't know after
what happened with urban how many teams
are going to be sniffing around the
college ranks right now yeah and that's
my last question for you albert i know i
i appreciate your time uh you and i have
not spoken since urban meyer has now
officially a fired head coach in the
national football league and you
obviously know the ohio state world very
well and you also you know know urban uh
through your association with the uh
with the school and whatnot yeah are you
even surprised that that this happened
uh are are you surprised that it
happened or not at all
where do you stand here on that i'll
fall on the sport here i you know i i
will say that
i have a trap that i'm gonna try to like
convince my i gotta try not to fall into
this trap but you know there's a lot of
these guys in the past and i i was this
way with chip kelly i think chip did an
okay job in philly like i don't think
chip's as bad as people make him out to
be you know what i mean like i think he
won 10 games two years in a row there
but i do think like a lot of times with
these guys i look at it and i'm like all
right like say super successful he's got
to be smart enough to know that he's
going to adjust right he's got to be
smart enough to know it can't go the
exact same way
and it just seems like it happens time
and again rich i i honestly don't even
really get it like why why they can't
adjust but
you know i i'd say like the the part of
the issue here was
like you know he went in and he did a
lot of things like he did in college he
couldn't handle losing and um you know i
had one of the coaches there say to me
it's like after they lost that
pre-season opener to the browns it was
like i mean it was like the world was
coming to an end it's like you can't
carry yourself that way in the league
you know what i mean like and that was
one of the questions we were all asking
how's he gonna handle a league where you
know you lose five games that's a great
year you know and so i think that that
was you know like that was certainly
part of it you know i think the fact
that you know he couldn't get his staff
the way he wanted it was part of it and
that's 100 on him that's not on those
guys that were on the staff you know and
then you know i i think the other part
of it that's pretty easy rich is if
you're going to coach that way if you're
going to be that demanding
you better get results fast because if
you don't get results fast and you keep
grinding on guys eventually they're
going to be they're gonna be saying like
what the hell am i going through all
this for and i remember having a
conversation with urban over the summer
about and i asked him how he's gonna do
it he said i'm gonna create value for
them right like he said like i'm gonna
create value we're gonna get them we're
gonna put them in a position to win and
we're going to put them in a position to
get paid because we're going to give
them the best we're going to give them
the best coaching staff we're giving
them the best facility we're going to
give them the best everything and
unfortunately for urban he couldn't
prove to the players fast enough that he
could provide that value and when it
became clear to the players that value
wasn't being provided for them they were
out on well i mean there's a difference
between demanding i mean i understand
that's demanding but it's
actually the the proper word for it is
demeaning
is what he did you know demeaning not
demanding i mean demanding is making
sure that you're getting the best not
not the fact that the fact that you're
losing means you're clearly not getting
the best it's just a process and how do
you not know that when you're given the
greatest golden goose situation from
trevor lawrence to an owner with
patience and money
and and no and no local media that's
going to be breathing down your neck
with five different you know radio
stations and television stations and no
state tax it's literally one of the
greatest
opportunities any coach has been
afforded in the nfl and he blew it i
mean that's just the only way to put it
you know and so that that's the that i
i am shocked that he still
couldn't see that okay the forest and
the trees the the the the uh the trees
are the losses but the forest is the
five-year contract and i'll get this
right and let's go so jimmy johnson won
one game in his first year i mean come
on like where i i
i don't know but then again i don't know
the guy i just worked with him that one
time on a draft and and then you know
interviewed him a couple times that's
that's about it and saw him at a super
bowl a couple times
i'll give you this i'll give you this
like anecdote like orion date was at one
of their practices in the um
in the in the spring or summer and i
know you know like a couple of the
coaches had said
kind of like mentioned him like you know
like hey like this is like this is
difficult you know because urban's way
was always never blame the players
always blame the coaches right
and
like so
ryan's response to this what response to
that wasn't what gay sort of surprise it
was like nope this guy's a this guy is a
mf to work with like you know like and
this is his offensive coordinator you
know what i mean like so like there's a
reality to it for coaches where it's i
mean it's more difficult for the coaches
to work for the guys the players no
doubt and like you said like there were
some guys who'd been in the league there
for 20 25 years and are i mean sitting
there having worked with the guy before
and are like like why is this guy
talking to me like this you know what i
mean like and when he and he wasn't
providing those guys with a ton of value
either and that was part of the i mean
again like i think that's part of the
issue is like like you can if you're
winning if you're giving everybody value
you can carry yourself however you want
the minute you don't all that stuff is
going to be scrutinized and obviously it
blew up in urban space in a spectacular
fashion albert thanks for the call
really appreciate it just always great
fun deep uh engaging chats with you but
you already know that uh have a great uh
christmas and holiday with your family
let's do this uh on the other side of
the year let's do this again awesome
thanks guys merry christmas to everybody
out there having awesome
oh by the way uh unfortunately the lump
of coal in your in your in your stocking
is uh i didn't get that new photograph
of you in a high-resolution form and
time to use it during this conversation
so all right that's all right i hope
that's high res enough for you we'll see
you guys have high standards over there
no you look good though you look good in
both of these photographs albert i'll be
honest
maybe i have low standards i don't know
take care of yourself
all right thanks guys
everybody hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here